[Musica]
non mi sono mai sentita una ragazza
straordinaria questo per me voleva dire
avere la fortuna di fare tutto quello
che fanno le persone la mia età quindi
uscire con gli amici andare alle feste
viaggiare studiare Eppure All'improvviso
lo straordinario piomba violentemente
nella mia vita il 9 settembre 2020 quel
giorno un giorno apparentemente normale
mia sorella Margherita la mia compagna
di giochi di di sorrisi parte per una
gita in montagna mette un piede
sbagliato su un sentiero e se ne va per
sempre
da quel giorno Ho imparato che azioni
sempre apparentemente normali mi
richiedevano invece Una forza
straordinaria questa forza fa sì che io
da due anni a questa parte viva ogni
giorno come su delle montagne russe con
emozioni intensissime in cui ogni
momento di gioia precede segue o è causa
di un momento di tristezza e viceversa
in questi due anni mi sono chiesta
spesso come sia possibile che però io
sia riuscita ad andare avanti Sono stati
due anni di dolore allo stato puro molto
spesso eppure in questi due anni sono
riuscita a laurearmi ho conosciuto
persone nuove ho fatto esperienze nuove
di cui porto ricordi bellissimi così
come non mi spiego come sia possibile
che su un sentiero di montagna percorso
da centinaia di persone proprio mia
sorella proprio quel giorno sia caduta e
se ne sia andata dalle nostre vite in
pochissimi secondi Così non mi so bene
spiegare come è possibile che io oggi
sia qua a parlare di questo non posso
quindi spiegarmelo in modo razionale ma
posso trovare dei pilastri quella che è
la mia vita nuova che è iniziata appunto
quel giorno quel giorno all'Ospedale di
Lecco guardando i miei genitori
affrontare il loro incubo peggiore
insieme noi tre abbiamo deciso di andare
avanti e guardare avanti Credo che
questa sia una caratteristica insita
dell'essere umano ed è sicuramente il
primo pilastro di quella che è la mia
vita nuova che non ho potuto scegliere
Ma che ho ricevuto e siamo riusciti
appunto a guardare avanti a non fermarci
e di certo non è stato solo questo che
ci ha salvato il secondo pilastro della
mia vita nuova è il potere della memoria
mia sorella
continua a essere presente nelle mie
giornate tramite centinaia di ricordi di
ricordi belli così come di ricordi
brutti Non passa giorno che non inizi
senza che io la pensi e a volte Appunto
nella nostra stanza giocare ridere e
scherzare a volte purtroppo in quel
letto di ospedale questi ricordi
soprattutto i ricordi belli dei momenti
sono stati insieme sono il motore che
spinge i miei passi verso il futuro e
credo che in un modo quasi paradossale
questi primi due pilastri siano legati
il fatto che io oggi sia qui e che nella
mia vita presente così come in quella
Futura drammaticamente mia sorella non
c'è più siano resi possibili dal fatto
che c'è stata dal fatto che il rapporto
così bello che abbiamo avuto definisce
in gran parte la persona che sono oggi
mi permette di essere qui e di fare
tutto quello che riesco a fare fino ad
ora ho parlato di me e di quello che io
ho potuto fare per me stessa e per
rialzarmi Ma se sono qui oggi non è di
certo solo merito mio e merito anche di
tutte quelle persone che mi hanno
accompagnato sul mio cammino quindi alla
mia famiglia e i miei amici l'incidente
di Margherita rappresentato anche per
loro una grandissima sfida e lo so l'ho
visto sulle loro facce il giorno del
funerale e lo vedo spesso Eppure non mi
hanno mai abbandonato e non mi hanno mai
abbandonato perché a volte Basta Proprio
così poco basta riuscire a chiedere
aiuto a qualcun altro e uscire il guscio
che giustamente noi tutti ci creiamo Ma
che una volta tolto può davvero aiutarci
a renderci migliori
i miei amici sono le persone con cui ho
scelto di camminare e non mi hanno mai
deluso Ma non sono gli unici nella rete
capillare di relazioni che ad oggi mi
aiuta a rimanere in piedi Infatti ci
sono due categorie di persone davvero
straordinarie sorprendenti che sono gli
amici di mia sorella gli amici dei miei
genitori gli amici di mia sorella il
giorno dell'incidente hanno chi 17 chi
18 anni cinque giorni dopo iniziano la
quarta la quinta superiore la loro vita
è tutta all'inizio siamo ai primi Le
prime uscite con gli amici Le prime
vacanze Cioè chi prende la patente chi
pensa all'università Eppure questa cosa
terribile colpisce anche loro e loro
però sono sempre riusciti a darmi la
forza di andare avanti Tramite la loro
insistenza la loro presenza nei nostri
vite e continuare a frequentare casa
nostra continuare a mettere sui social
delle foto di Margherita e continuare ad
avere quel sorriso con i quali io da
sorella maggiore li ho visti crescere
tutto questo appunto mi ha dato una
forza straordinaria
gli amici dei miei genitori sono una
categoria un pochino più difficile da
inquadrare sono quegli adulti di cui noi
giovani spesso diffidiamo Eppure per me
Da quel giorno sono una parte
fondamentale della mia vita molti di
loro sono diventati come dei genitori
adottivi e sulle loro facce
probabilmente prima anche su quelle dei
miei genitori che ho capito la gravità e
la comprensione adulta di quello che
c'era realmente successo Sono loro che
hanno tenuto il nostro frigorifero e la
nostra casa piena per tutti i mesi
subito dopo l'incidente e che non ci
hanno ancora mollato neanche di un
millimetro e sono loro che si
interessano continuamente ai miei piani
mi fanno complimenti per cose che io non
ritengo neanche degne di complimenti e
che mi fanno pensare davvero che che ce
la posso fare che posso andare avanti
soprattutto sono loro e loro contributo
che ci ha aiutato a mettere in piedi due
progetti e ricordo di Margherita ad oggi
attivi
il primo progetto è per me è una vera e
propria magia è un coro in cui cantano
insieme volontari e ragazzi portatori di
handicap ci piace chiamarlo un
arcobaleno di voci perché ognuno di noi
ha il suo colore tramite la musica e
l'interazione con gli altri può
esprimersi Senza vergogna Il secondo
progetto è stato reso possibile tramite
a una parte fondamentale della vita mia
e di Margherita che è l'esperienza scout
insieme ai ragazzi del nostro gruppo
Abbiamo rimesso in uso una Canonica
abbandonata sopra a Luino e ed è un
posto che oggi davvero sentiamo di poter
Chiamare casa per noi per i ragazzi oggi
membri del nostro gruppo per i ragazzi
che arriveranno e per tutte quelle
persone che credono nell'amicizia e
nello stare insieme come fondamenta di
un progetto di vita e di un progetto
educativo
per concludere sento davvero che quello
che questa mia esperienza di vita
straordinaria che assolutamente non ho
potuto scegliere Ma che mi è capitata
meriti appunto di lasciare qualcosa a
tutti ed è la consapevolezza del fatto
che lo straordinario è davvero dentro di
noi che può essere rianimato da eventi
che non devono essere ovviamente
drammatici e che però ognuno di noi può
davvero essere protagonista della sua
vita basandosi su questi che credo siano
in tre pilastri quindi la capacità di
guardare avanti la forza del ricordo e
l'affidarsi a una rete di relazioni
presente da sempre le nostre vite Grazie
a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]